[перемовляються по рації]
[російською] Чуєш, в сторону, бо під'їжджають клієнти.
[російською] Давайте, три людини сюди.
[російською] Поїхали, поїхали, поїхали, молодець!
[російською] Працюємо, працюємо, працюємо.
[російською] Ви щось наплутали.
[російською] 30 [гривень] мінімум, 50 — максимум.
[російською] Багаті — 50, середні — 30.
[російською] Звідки ви?
[російською] У нас така традиція.
Там красиво за цим парканом, чесно.
[російською] Давайте ще одного, допоможіть.
Тут багато людей.
[російською] Всі документи підготуйте до огляду.
[російською] І по п'ять гривень до чаю,
бо вода закінчилася.
[російською] Колядку заспівайте!
[російською] Давайте!
♪ Добрий вечір тобі, пане господарю. Радуйся! ♪
♪ Ой радуйся, земле, Син Божий народився! ♪
— Слава Україні!
— Героям Слава!
— Зі святом вас!
— Скажи, хай двадцятку поверне.
— Повертайте...
— Нехай двадцятку поверне!
[усі сміються]
[російською] Там серйозні люди.
[російською] Там жива музика, усе там живе.
[російською] Ми пропускаємо [людей],
даємо їм квиточки, аби всім було зручно.
[російською] Пропускаємо, пропускаємо!
[шелестить солома]
Більше немає?
[російською] У кожній хаті роблять одного або двох Ведмедів.
[російською] Не знаю, скільки у нас,
але було 35-40 Ведмедів.
[російською] Тут п'ять кутів.
— [російською] Є он хлопці, які Ведмеді уже скільки років...
— [російською] Поки не одружаться.
[російською] Можуть сім років поспіль бути Ведмедем.
[російською] Одружені одягають на обличчя маски:
Баби, Діда або Жида.
[покашлює]
— [румунською] Все.
— [румунською] Все? А на спині?
[румунською] Зачекай, зачекай.
— [румунською] А на спині?
— [румунською] Тільки піднімайся.
[румунською] Що робиш, Гришо?
— [румунською] Діставай! Обережно, бо порвеш.
— [румунською] Не бійся.
[румунською] Порвеш, Петре!
[румунською] Давай, давай, піднімайся.
[сміються]
[румунською] Подай берці.
[собака гавкає]
[російською] Ну що, доробляй його.
Овва! Мій брат має шість років — уже в Маланці.
Я з трьох років.
Був маленьким ведмедиком таким у шубі.
Багато років вже.
Прадідо мій був теж у Маланці,
тато мій був два роки Комендантом.
[говорять між собою румунською]
♪ [румунською] Ми не відступимо, не здамося.
Хоча знаємо, що тріснемо. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ми тріснемо, розколемося,
і нічого нам не зроблять. ♪
[свистять, кричать та
створюють вигуками атмосферу свята]
Бо у них в крові це, традиція в крові.
Маленькі ходять, теж уже співають [мелодію] «Урсу» [Ведмеді].
Всі збиралися і почали [планувати],
хто буде робити, то взяли й мене.
Це мій брат двоюрідний, сусіди. Це всі мої друзі.
Тут має виходити, тут десять [Ведмедів]...
Десять, тут ще п'ять. Так, тут має бути сім [Ведмедів].
[російською] І так буде до ранку.
[російською] І завтра те ж саме.
[чоловік б'є батогом об землю]
[гавкає собака]
[російською] Цього року буде вже третій рік,
[російською] коли зі станком ткацьким ходили.
[російською] Я тоді один раз був Бабою.
[російською] А так переважно Дідом.
[російською] Циганом були.
[російською] Давно, вже й не пам'ятаю, коли.
[російською] Там ще є маски.
[російською] Спочатку змочуємо папір.
[російською] Щоб вона не прилипла до маски.
[російською] Ось ця вже готова. Треба її пофарбувати,
[російською] додати хустку і все інше.
Це буде Баба.
[російською] А це не знаю, хто буде — Дід чи Дід Мороз.
[російською] Не було такого,
щоб два роки поспіль я був в одній масці.
[російською] Побачив у знайомого і сам собі зробив.
[російською] Сподобалося робити.
[російською] Я взагалі люблю наші традиції.
[російською] У нас своя компанія — п'ятнадцять людей.
[російською] Щороку робимо щось нове,
але за нашими старовинними звичаями,
[російською] щоб молодь не забувала.
[російською] Адже раніше все робили самі.
[російською] Показуємо, але вони все одно всі виїхали закордон.
[російською] У Радянському Союзі нас ловили
і не пускали на центральну дорогу.
[російською] Міліція і навіть прикордонники.
[російською] Це була ніби війна.
[російською] Але все одно виходили.
Ніхто не міг їх стримати.
[чоловік рве папір і тканину]
[російською] Це мій особистий персонаж.
[російською] Я жодну свою [маску] не віддаю.
Хіба знайомим, але за умови повернення.
[російською] Я тримаю їх собі на пам'ять, у мене їх багато.
[звучать все гучніше співи,
насвистування та ритми барабанів]
[дзвенять дзвоники,
люди активно говорять між собою]
[учасник дійства грає на бугаї —
музичному інструменті]
[румунською] А в нових хатах не знайдеш зараз печі.
[румунською] Ні печі, ні плити. Паровими обладнали.
[румунською] Роблять теплі підлоги,
вночі сплять біля котла.
[румунською] А наші предки, коли жили, у печі хліб пекли.
[румунською] Ми зараз не випікаємо, у Мицу купуємо.
[румунською] Цей хліб такий пухнастий,
що сам лізе до рота.
♪ [румунською] Давай ще раз, Маланко, щоб почула інша. ♪
♪ [румунською] Бо ти — ведмідь з лісу.
Спіймали тебе, коли ти їв ягоди. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ти ягоди з'їв, а ведмедиця злякалася. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ми — цигани з шатра,
спіймали чотирьох ведмедів одразу. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ланцюгами пов'язали,
у домівці сховали. ♪
[гомінливе маланкове дійство]
♪ [румунською] Хай живе Маланка та хлопці з Путни. ♪
♪ [румунською] Нехай буде та з Суса,
хлопців, як з Путни, нема. ♪
♪ [румунською] Тьфу ти, мати твоя, руський. ♪
♪ [румунською] Та й той, хто його привіз,
та назад не відвіз. ♪
♪ [румунською] На місці, на місці,
щоб росла волошка. ♪
[гомінливе маланкове дійство]
♪ [румунською] Ми тріснемо, розколемося,
і нічого нам не зроблять. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ми станемо спиною до спини,
тоді побачимо, хто нас поб'є. ♪
♪ [румунською] Ми станемо лицем до лиця,
тоді побачимо, хто має рацію. ♪
[дзвонять дзвоники,
люди емоційно спілкуються між собою]
[румунською] Господар цієї хати подарував Маланці 600 грн.
Бажаємо йому здоров'я та многая літа!
[люди вигукують]
[румунською] Маланка йде до Пірата [прізвисько господаря].
[румунською] Трішки після відпочинку.
[гомінливе маланкове дійство]
♪ [румунською] Як півень на курку, ♪
♪ [румунською] та й курка на півня, ♪
♪ [румунською] щоб курчата були гарненькі ♪
♪ [румунською] і стрибали, як Змєу [герой румунської міфології]. ♪
♪ [румунською] І хто полізе, ♪
♪ [румунською] мечукою [дубиною] отримає по голові. ♪
[румунською] Три бідони на вуха.
Вставай, Республіка «Цигани»!
[гомінливе маланкове дійство]
♪ [румунською] Гоп, гоп, олей гоп!
Ведмідь клишоногий! ♪
Звідки взявся на мою голову? ♪
[гомінливе маланкове дійство]